all right
you can't spend the night not all night
so where'd you move here from anyway
Eastern Shore
[Music]
try that
[Music]
dad you didn't when the cops get here
you have to be good and gone I can't
help you anymore I know it's not your
fault you were born this way you ate
them I believed you had to I don't know
why
foreign
I thought I was the only one
I don't want to hurt anybody
famous last words
[Music]
I don't actually meet my
[Music]
money I am nice
okay I'm looking for you I smelled you
you could smell me half mile away
can you do that not that far I got a
rule never never ever eat an eater
I thought you might be hungry for hands
no who lives here is there someone dead
up there
[Music]
I'm not gonna be like that we don't have
many options either you eat you off
yourself or you lock yourself up in
there we're dangerous
one of us Jake's teaching me how to
smell other eaters but we can hurt one
another just as bad
[Music]
too much
you gotta do this we have to do it
you've been following me and we got
unfinished business
you know I'm thinking of a bad person
[Music]
oh I think is that I love you